la colère des libanais est
assourdissante
quatre jours après une double explosion
qui a meurtri la ville de beyrouth et
ses habitants il n'y avait aucun doute
sur la cible de leur fureur les
différents tableaux navale ils nous ont
fait perdre notre dignité ils ont marché
dessus dit fatima dont le neveu est mort
mardi dernier
nous ne voulons plus qu'aucun d'entre
nous représente c'est le peuple qui se
représentent
assez c'est assez nous avons perdu
beyrouth nos familles nos enfants crient
cette femme a un soldat qu'attendez vous
posez votre arme et tenez vous à mes
côtés
un peu plus loin il a fallu peu de temps
pour que la tension palpable ne dégénère
entre policiers et soldats déployés en
masse et les manifestants le centre
ville de beyrouth s'est retrouvé
obscurci par la fumée des gaz
tout ce qui pouvait servir de
projectiles aux manifestantes
et ce ne sont pas les débris qui
manquent ces jours ci a été utilisé ces
confrontations entre les manifestants et
les policiers se sont poursuivis pendant
plusieurs heures un jeu du chat et de la
souris avec des gaz lacrymogènes contre
des tirs de pierres une confrontation de
plus en plus violente
au fil du temps c'est une chose
inacceptable ils ont pris en otage le
parlement le parlement appartient au
peuple et pas eux et avec tout ça on va
leur prendre si c'est pas ce soir ce
sera demain et on leur prend leur a des
blessés y aura des morts et c'est le cas
les responsables
un policier est mort en intervenant dans
un hôtel incendié par les protestataires
selon les autorités plus d'une centaine
de manifestants ont été blessés selon
des sources médicales
des édifices publics dont le ministère
de l'économie ont été investis par les
manifestants et un groupe d'officiers de
l'armée à la retraite a quant à lui
forcer les portes du ministère des
affaires étrangères sur les banderoles
qu'ils ont déployés pu lire beyrouth
ville sans armes
une référence au hezbollah et berry
capitale grecque
buffon le premier ministre libanais
hassan diab a annoncé qu'il allait
proposer des élections parlementaires
anticipées pour sortir le pays de ce
qu'il a avec une crise structurelle
après les chants injuriant crûment le
président michel aoun et toute la classe
politique et cette potence érigée place
des martyrs le choix que ferait ces
libanais semble clair si on leur ferait
une alternative aux pauvres ce qu'on
nous enlève cette classe corrompu qu'on
nous enlève leurs amis
et dans un liban ou dynastie politique
confessionnel ils n'ont pour le moment
guère plus cette rage incendiaires ici
marie-eve bédard radio canada béroud